elle a participé à sa finale et donc il
va falloir tout démonter tout vérifié
puisque on est vraiment sur des voitures
de compétition qui sont assez sensibles
à l'usure s'il s'agit d'un modèle réduit
hors de question de prendre cette
voiture radiocommandée pour un jouet
donc là j'ai pas fais nettoyage complet
du moteur habituellement on démonte tout
on nettoie tout dans du produit exprès
et à des pneus niveau d'huile embrayage
autant de paramètres à vérifier avant de
retourner sur le circuit christophe est
un habitué cela fait trente ans qu'il
participe à des compétitions
je suis plutôt dans les vétérans on va
dire je fais encore des compétitions
nationales
dans l'autre catégorie que j'ai pratiqué
pendant pas mal d'années j'étais au
niveau championnat de france élite et
championnats d'europe plus que j'ai fait
un podium de championnat d'europe donc
une troisième place à brest et puis
l'année d'avant j'avais fait 4e
aujourd'hui responsable de la section
tout terrain ou modélisme morta club est
passé côté organisation parce qu'on
arrive avec pas mal de vitesse on se
retrouve mal placé pour la table
américaine qui est juste derrière
l'association accueille des 23 et 24
juin une manche championnat de france à
quelques jours de la rencontre
il s'assure du bon état du terrain
j'ai fait quelques tours de circuit pour
valider les travaux qu'on a pu réaliser
pour préparer ce terrain propre
championnat de france donc l'objectif
c'était de valider que les boss a sauté
correctement que les raccords entre les
différents revêtements du circuit ne
posait pas de problème est que le
traitement qu'on a fait sur la piste va
aussi va donner entière satisfaction
puisque a beaucoup de rythme parce qu'il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'endroits on peut se
reposer et vraiment dire un peu se
décontracter terre bois avait bossé
ligne droite
un terrain varié de deux mètres carrés
plus de 100 pilotes s'élanceront sur le
circuit